you talk about a a tight race at the top
of the conference it's going to go down
to the wire too aren't yeah let's let's
take a look because you saw you saw
Denver win you saw Minnesota win uh
identical records of 36 and 16 look at
OKC right there at 35 and 16 and the
Clippers who have been smoking right
behind them and oh by the way uh the
Phoenix Suns New Orleans Pelicans have
quietly been playing Super Ball in are
nine games over 500 so do we have time
to talk uh yeah that's what we do Kenny
I asked you earlier you don't want to be
four no I'm I asked you earlier what do
you what do you think about Gordon
Haywood going to the Thunder I think you
know healthy healthy Gordon Haywood is
one thing or or they you know up and
down you know they he brings veteran
leadership he brings things off the
bench you could start them at times well
he's coming off the bench for sure but
you can have different lineups huh they
don't need them yeah well it's it's good
to have veteran leadership coming off
the bench they're a young team I don't
think anybody on their team has ever
been anywhere close to going deep in the
playoffs to have a veteran guy in the
locker room and coming off the bench I
think I think that could be a good
pickup for the Thunder the one thing I
was saying sh I I just don't when I
saying you don't want to be four you
know as we watch Gordon Haywood
because five and six are going to be
really good teams right now that's
Phoenix and New Orleans so like it's not
if you're the four seed and you have to
start out with one of those two teams or
vice versa those three teams if they end
up 456 that is a tough tough matchup uh
for anyone one two and three you can get
out the first round pretty easily and if
you're because you're going to be
overmatched matching the team I I I
disagree with champ cuz Three G three
might be playing the Pelicans and Kenny
yeah three and three and four are going
to be in for some first round if you're
a real Champion you want to get the
tough teams out of the way anyway don't
matter that's not that's not the way
it's gone work if you first of all first
of all you been there five times I've
been there I don't care you don't you're
not going to play you're not going to
play I don't want to hear I don't care
how loud you are you're not going to
play no bad teams in the in the once you
get past the first running away from the
tough teams let's running away from the
tough team you got to play tough teams
deeper in the playoffs louder louder no
he just said you don't want to be four
cuz I don't want to play boom and Bam I
want to play boom and Bam early get him
out of there but he that those aren't
the team that got to beat he was talking
about the looking and the Suns you going
to have to play you going to have to
play the Clippers you going to have to
play the Clippers and the Nuggets he up
here talking like he's scared I want to
get that's not what he said two
different things that's not what he said
two different things between that's not
what he said I don't want to play them
or I don't think I can beat them the
reason is I know that they can play
deeper in the so I don't want to go into
six seven games and beat them I'm not
sweeping those guys so okay I I'm
sweeping seven and eight we're going to
get rest because I can't take the chance
that Dame Lillard Twisted an ankle Anto
tupo I can't take a chance Oak uh Shay
gild getting uh tired hurt I can't just
take the chance let me get one round
through and then I'm ready okay all bets
off because I just don't want to play
six games in the first round care I
don't care who we playing in the first
round how about okay I don't care who we
playing I'd rather not play but I think
I think Kenny's point was if you if you
show the list again you put the
standards back up we can do that he
scared of the Suns no that's is he's not
nobody scared of anybody we're
all can you put the stats back up please
he's scared of the sons that's not what
he said don't matter what he said the
way I think the way I think this thing
is going to finish it's going to be the
Clippers and the Nuggets going to be one
and two what Shaq what Kenny's point was
if you're the Thunder of the Wolves
playing the
Pelicans or the signs that's going to be
a hell of a series okay but I want to
get the three juggernauts out the way I
the J at the top we're talking about the
first round of the playoff book and a
bill can take over a game all they need
is two good two good games out that's
what he said why he's saying that's
that's why that's what K said I want to
take Kevin Durant out I want to get his
ass up the whole playoff you worried
about him over the Joker uh the first
round yeah no no I don't want that in
first why not give me rest I want to
rest cuz I want to be somebody and keep
it moving no you do not want this smoke
young
fell that was a lot of fun shoo that
spot sh
bring oh number
two